um you can't defend them anymore you
know Harry I defended him all along said
look he's protected his country served
his country he should go off like they
wanted to go off and live their life
outside of the media outside the
Limelight privacy with waiting for the
media and I completely respected that I
thought to myself you know what the man
served his country let him get away they
didn't mean to me but to then do the
complete opposite not the complete
opposite discreetly the complete
opposite in the face in our faces not
only the people of our of his country
which we we did look at him as our
Prince but also the monarchy you know I
served the monarchy I swore an
allegiance yeah you know I fought for
Harry for William for the queen for the
king I fought for those people
um during you know during a couple of
decades so when I see now that I've not
only defended him but he's come out and
the wokeness behind it the virtual
signaling behind this is is sickening
now people I think people have got to
the point where they're they're fed up
with hearing the same old but also and
then making money out